los pólipos nasales son tejidos blandos
que han crecido en el revestimiento de
la nariz también pueden crecer en los
espacios llenos de aire cerca de la
nariz llamados senos nasales
los pólipos se pueden irritar hinchar o
infectar
pueden crecer lo suficiente como para
bloquear el flujo de aire por la nariz
para tratar sus pólipos su proveedor de
atención médica puede probar con
medicamentos como antibióticos un
aerosol nasal con esteroides o un
medicamento para alergias si los
medicamentos no funcionan es posible que
su proveedor de atención médica les
recomienda extirpar los pólipos este
procedimiento se llama polipectomía
nasal
en este procedimiento el cirujano
inserta una herramienta delgada con una
cámara en el extremo dentro de la nariz
las imágenes de la cámara se envían a
una pantalla para que el cirujano pueda
ver los pólipos
luego el cirujano extrae los pólipos
después del procedimiento su proveedor
de atención médica puede pedirle que use
un enjuague con solución salina y otros
medicamentos para ayudarle a mantener
abiertas las vías respiratorias hablé
con su proveedor de atención médica para
obtener más información sobre la poli
pecto mía nasal